could there be financial irregularities  in the National Front maybe or laughs  the European anti-fraud office is to  investigate following an inquiry by  Parliament's administration President  Schultz has called on Olaf to probe  claims against twenty MEP assistance in  the party they're suspected of working  for marine lepen National Front in Paris  rather than on there EU parliamentary  duties on a papaya papaya lapalma over  PA el caballo and party on at a tilaka  come to Lisa praca de honor a soup sound  in the irregularity news sums of leisure  says here Olaf a logistics the bacon  sarnie Olaf will now investigate but the  fraud is set to amount to 1.5 million  euros per year for all 20 assistance  money which is paid out of the EU budget